what is it about this writing style
that's so slippery that i just can't get
it's like a tick tock feed i can't get
out of it you know and so
i would say it's like more like a door
where you kind of got to go knock and
take a leap of faith that there is
something on the other side of this you
can't see exactly what you're going to
get until the door opens
[Music]
all right we're live cool sweatshirt um
what's going on
oh dude i already told you i couldn't i
can't talk about it on on air but i am
uh
you know there's some days where a fire
there's a fire on the third floor and
you gotta grab the extinguisher and go
put it out and so that's what i've been
doing today is putting out and i'm glad
that i did this which is we had a bunch
of family coming in town for
thanksgiving
wife was like oh yeah it's great we got
my sister coming we got this person
coming this person's coming from india
it's like oh god okay um she's like you
know we should host thanksgiving i said
you know i love the giving spirit i love
the idea
but we're not hosting anything on
thanksgiving why because we have an
e-commerce company and black friday is
the biggest sales day of the year and
she said well what are we gonna do like
you know it's just gonna sell online
like
we're not gonna go to the warehouse or
something and go fulfill it you know so
what do we do i said
sometimes you gotta create space cause
you just wanna be available you wanna
have buffer you don't wanna be fully
booked in case you need to do it maybe
you have an idea that something you can
do to drive sales or in this case
what if [__] absolutely hit the fan and
you had to do something to recover which
is exactly what happened today i created
space my ceo was like
oh i'm just going to go pick this person
up from the airport that day it should
be no problem guess what she's in the
car
the shit's hitting the fan and she can't
get to a computer and she's did not
create enough space and so that was a
great that's an evolution for you
because you are not the man at creating
something he's not a space creator uh
that's that's come with you know some
gray hairs in wisdom is is this idea so
i'm glad i did it because shit's hitting
the fan today and you know i'm just
hoping that i told you before this i'm
hoping that uh you know my my safety
my savings my under the mattress savings
of good luck needs to be cashed in today
i'm just i'm reaching under the mattress
i'm hoping it's still there i feel like
i put it there i'm hoping that good luck
is still there i need it today
well okay so i've got so what we're
gonna i we're gonna talk about uh
products and media that we like but and
i have a couple i have one thing in
particular that's gonna make a
difference on your day today actually
okay um we can talk about it later but
so today's episode is we're gonna talk
about products and media that we've
consumed throughout the year that we
think are cool because i like talking
about gadgets and and media and so do
you um the stuff that you talked about
laps last episode was actually quite
amazing uh that article about um
uh
data and how it's easy to uh read data
yeah just kind of like a great find it's
kind of is that the idea right fine
these these are exactly fines we've had
this year whether it's a product or it's
a piece of content
great finds i think that's in the the
thanksgiving spirit it's like you know
being thankful for it but also
people have time
hopefully people are creating a little
space you know you spend some family
time and uh but but me people have time
over the holidays and this is a good
chance to either buy this as a gift for
yourself or somebody else or to just
check something out that you haven't
tried before
all right well let's start do you uh you
name one and i'll name one or i can name
a couple what do you want to do okay
let's do let's i think we both have an
app that we really like uh two different
apps so let's do the category of apps so
what's a great find you had that's an
app this year
okay z unfortunately a lot of things i
might name are going to involve fitness
a lot of them are going to be money
related this influence your
a lot of them will be money related
though actually and relaxation and
mindset so uh the first one zero it's
called zero i believe kevin rose started
it okay so i i never thought that i was
intermittent fasting but in order just
not to overeat throughout the day i just
wouldn't eat breakfast turns out that's
called intermittent fasting
that's not why i did it um this app
called xero it's free they have a paid
version which honestly i don't think it
does anything but the free version you
you say when you had your last meal and
it just tells you don't eat until and
then you uh in my case it's 16 hours
it's awesome i love it i can't believe
how that one app actually makes me want
to stick to it as opposed to when i'm on
my own so that's that app has made a
meaningful change in mind what are you
fasting you're doing 16 16-8 are you
doing more intense than that i do i do
16-8 so basically i'll stop eating at 8
00 p.m and i'll eat again at noon
right so six that means 16 hours not
eating eight hours eating and when you
eat in your eight hours
are you like
you know eating kale salads or you eat
whatever you want in those eight hours
what do you want i don't eat whatever i
want i usually eat meat and vegetables
that's what i i work hard to do
size no portion sizing within that eight
hours you're fine you eat until you're
full
um
yeah i i portion control yeah definitely
i i very yeah for sure i try to eat 2
500 calories
a day good good um all right so i have
uh anything else on xero i think that's
a that's a good run i've tried it as
well
i like it it's a super clean interface
it's like i like apps that just do one
thing really well and that's what that
does
um okay here's an app i think i've
talked about this but i got big into
breath work
and so there's two apps that if you want
to have kind of like a happier life
there's a lot of apps that will distract
you instagram tick tock whatever there's
apps that'll make you more productive
but they'll distract you from the real
world that's like email slack maybe
twitter
and then there's apps that actually
center you and ground you and so
my phone had enough of the distraction
apps i had enough of the productivity
apps where i was lacking was
hey how can i use this magic wand that's
how i think of my phone it's a magic
wand i make i just
i install an app and that's like a spell
that just could do some magic thing i
can get food to appear at my doorstep or
i can you know summon a car or i can do
all kinds of different crazy stuff i can
put my you know my mom thousands of
miles away her face can show up on my
phone well this one gets me grounded and
so there's two apps i want to call out
one i think we've talked about before
it's called the five minute journal
um i ended up meeting the guy who who
who made this app
i didn't know that was an app i thought
it was a notebook
there is a notebook and then there's the
app apps
it's a paid app i think it's three bucks
or five bucks or something like that
which is so funny because when i saw
that i was like i don't pay for apps i
was like wow like my threshold for
paying for [__] on a phone is so low
compared to like
a parking it's a parking meter but i get
to use this app forever that some guy
created and coded and makes it do all
these things so
five bucks and what it does is you open
it up and it basically just has a quote
while it loads it's always a good quote
they do they have good selection and
then it basically says what are three
things you're grateful for today and the
act of writing those down is
great this looks great um
you know not to get super cheesy but
basically the more grateful you are the
less stressed you are you cannot be
grateful and stressed at the same time
you cannot be grateful and afraid at the
same time you cannot be grateful and
angry at the same time so if you just
want to not be any of those bad things
just focus on being grateful rather than
not being whatever it's like when you
tell somebody relax when they're really
pissed off guess what they don't really
relax very well so you're telling
somebody to not be angry or not be
stressed doesn't work but telling but
getting somebody to shift their focus to
being grateful works actually really
well what questions does it ask just
says what three what three things happen
today that you're grateful for and it's
today it's things that happen today not
like what are three things in your life
that you're grateful for then you just
sort of monotonously you say my health
my family and my friends it's like no
what happened today that i'm grateful
for what's a moment of today then it
forces you to slow down time because
you're like [__] what did i even eat for
lunch today what did i do today
and then you're like you think of one
thing and you're like god there must
have been something more than that that
i'm grateful for you kind of suck at it
the first day they suck at it the second
day by the third day something happens
during the day and you're like ah i'm
gonna write this in the app tonight um
like that's the thing and so it forces
you during the day to actually take note
of what you're grateful for which makes
you a more grateful person all
right uh let me just tell you something
really quick so andrew hueberman one of
the things on my list andrew huberman
recently had a new video come on come
out called the science of gratitude and
how to build a gratitude practice andrew
huberman was on our podcast he's got
this amazing pod youtube channel where
he talks about the science behind
different things and how you can use it
to help you and his latest thing is on
gratitude and he says that he's been
doing gratitude and
i don't want to get into the signs but
basically there's something about like
the prefrontal cortex and how gratitude
actually releases dopamine and it's
proven to make you more motivated and
happy and he said a lot of people
including him did exactly what you did
and he goes i think that's works but we
have loads of studies that show that the
actually slightly more effective way is
to do one of two things and i believe
those it is um
you try
so the most effective thing is that you
you read or you remember you read
something that someone has written to
you and so someone's expressing
gratitude to you of course that's not
entirely practical right
and so there's uh
a few things that you can do the first
thing is that you can
think of a story when someone was
helpful to you and if you if you focus
hard enough it actually
feels real and the second thing that
that i do me and my wife is every couple
days we have a set time that we sit down
and we say here's what i'm thankful i'm
thankful that that you did this and then
the second thing that you can do is you
can actually think of a story and my
life just do the opposite we just say
everything we hate about each other
every two days and uh and then that
sounds good then we get to get it off
our chest she loves she's really good at
the game i'm getting better uh it's just
it's a good thing it's called the
hateful eight just eight minutes of just
like hating on each other
um and uh the second thing that you
could do is you can think of a story of
of someone being helpful to another
person and they put these guys i believe
in a mri and they scan their brain and
they watched a movie or a story about
holocaust survivors being helped and
surviving and it like changed something
in their brain and it was proven to make
them more motivated
why is that the most convincing thing
ever everything that they're like they
did an fmri study they scan people while
they watch this
the brain lights up like a christmas
tree it's like the most like that's the
most i'm just gonna make that up
whenever i want to be more convincing
with my thing i'm like yeah people who
buy my my power writing course uh
we've done brain scans it shows that
actually there are there you know how
there's a part of your brain you can't
access with this course you actually
access it the scans they speak for
themselves i did a transcendental
meditation thing and uh it's like a
style of meditation and they like i went
to the seminar and they're like it's
proven with brain stance to be different
than mindfulness and i was like
really i mean like you're both you're
you're they're kind of the same thing
you're being quiet and just like
like i don't understand how but anyway
that's what they said so uh anyway go
ahead your second thing well one more on
that great gratefulness thing there's
one other technique that i it's less
convenient but when you do it it's
awesome it's called flooding have you
ever heard of this no
all right flooding is when you basically
you create a flood of memories of great
moments in your life the easiest way to
do it is you open up a photo album
and you flip through it or you go
through your camera roll so if like me
and my wife we get together we'll have
our camera roll open and we'll just be
showing each other photos from you know
three years ago remember that trip
remember that day remember this thing we
did laughing about it what happened that
day
and just if you just do that for even 10
minutes you just revisit those photos
i'm not a big photo guy i actually hate
taking photos in the moment i find it to
be just incredibly like off-putting and
my wife's like the opposite she loves
taking photos of everything but i gotta
admit this flooding [__] is amazing it
works i literally love her more after we
do it because i remember all these
amazing times i've had with her and i
don't have to try i just like look at
the photo and it's there it's better
than better than my imagination so
that's what you're gonna have to do
today in order to get over your
heartache your money loss i know i know
we'll have to figure it out one more app
one more app so the other app is called
othership uh so this is this just came
out i invested in this thing because i'm
a believer in it i struggled with
meditation meditation was very hard for
me so even though i was friends with the
founders of calm
and they gave me a free account or
whatever never really used it couldn't
couldn't get myself to enjoy doing it
and i'm the type where if i don't enjoy
it it's just very hard for me to stick
with anything i don't enjoy i don't have
enough willpower or don't want enough
willpower i don't know what it is but
i'm not great at it
so i wanted the benefits of meditation
but i didn't enjoy doing it
breath work has become like a revelation
to me it's a form of meditation
it's very similar
but
focusing on
breath and a guided breath work session
so i've tried wim hof loved it wim hof
has a great app too it's a free app and
other ship is like a souped-up version
of wim hof
and uh this guy robbie created it he's
amazing at it he guides a lot of the
meditations himself
he built his own like home
oasis in his he was like really early at
ethereum hey like he was the first
marketing guy at the ethereum foundation
when it was like whatever
you know
60 cents or something so it's just like
mega rich so he got like you know even
with barely putting any money in he got
like kind of loaded and then he sold
some of it and was like okay i'm gonna
turn like half of my i'm gonna make this
huge like kind of cabin out of the
garage type thing like a mega garage he
turned it into like this like 20 person
sauna plus cold plunge plus like amazing
meditation room plus greenhouse and all
this other [__] you went to it uh no
he's invited me it's in canada i haven't
gone yet but um
it's amazing he hosts a lot of people
there he invited us actually so you're
welcome to go anytime
and um they do like guided whatever like
microdosing lsd if you want to do that
or whatever no you can do you can do
anything you can do anything in this
place
long story short he got really into
breath work along this journey and cr
now this is what he does he's like i'm
gonna i created this app i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring breathwork to the masses and
i do it every morning and it's amazing
so that's my uh other ship is the name
of the app
all right i dig that all right i'll i'll
tell you one all right so there's this
subreddit that i go to and i love it
it's called
uh fat fire and the idea is people who
want to retire relatively young with a
lot of money so they can live a fat life
without working
and there's this guy and so basically if
you post on there a lot the mods the
community leaders of the subreddit will
verify your net worth to make your sure
you're not full of [__] by the way did
you have a goal like this like i want to
retire by x age or i want to be like
yeah this wealthy by this age what was
your like how did you phrase your goal
uh i i wanted to have 20 million dollars
by age 30.
gotcha all right that's what i wanted
that was my goal i created that goal
when i was in my uh when i was like 19
or 20 years old
i mean i can't confirm or deny but you
know mission accomplished is what i
would say i i sold my couple i i
achieved it at 31. i sold my company at
31 right um and so my that was my goal
because i asked
a rich person who i knew i asked them
how much money do you spend a month
and they told me 60 000 a month
and at the time i was like i don't know
like i can't imagine there's a world
where i was absolutely weird yeah yeah
i'm like that just sounds crazy but
whatever like i asked like eight people
and this person had the highest number
and i was like okay i'll just do that
because i'll be conservative and then if
you withdraw only three percent of your
20 million that gives you like six
hundred thousand dollars uh a year to
spend there that that's what that number
is that's that's that's right fire
philosophy and fire stands for
financially independent retire early so
yes so you can you can you can spend uh
a percentage of your portfo of your
liquid portfolio and
basically it continues to grow have
enough money
that the
earnings the the the sort of compounding
earnings on the money being invested in
something safe like the stock market s p
500 type of thing
can um
can cover your burn rate so there's two
things that matter what is the what is
the amount that i have invested and what
is my life burn rate that's why a lot of
people who like fire they go move to
like you know bum [__] you know middle
of nowhere and they they're like oh yeah
i got rid of my car and it's great now i
can you know i got rid of everything i
own and me and my wife we only eat apple
cores and now we're retired it's like
but fat fire is different fat fire is
like now i kind of want to ball out i'm
not trying to like skimp on my lifestyle
so okay what do i need to achieve and
what do i need to optimize while still
not giving up
like what i find to be enjoyable in
terms of lifestyle yeah so that's how i
made up that number and i don't even i
spend fifteen thousand dollars a month
so i don't spend even close to that but
i i saw this thing yesterday
which is somebody was saying
they posted like my company here's what
my company's revenues were for the this
i think i said chris cantino uh it was
like
oh company's revenues for the first
seven years and it was like you know
zero thousand
twenty thousand fifty thousand hundred
fifty thousand three hundred fifty
thousand seven million twenty one
million or something like that right i
i'm making it up but there's some slow
build and then suddenly things really
take off and i think they sold their
company it was a soap company i think uh
for 100 million dollars i think i have
that right is that correct you know this
guy
no i know who you're talking about
though he tweets great stuff you said
his name right yeah so okay so so he
tweeted that and i got me thinking i was
like
it's it's true a lot of success i would
say the common
you know when success comes through the
front door this is how it arrives slowly
and then suddenly when it rains it pours
when it rains it pours and i started
thinking okay is that true in my life
and i started writing down i wrote down
how much money i made from the age 20 to
the age 31 because i also got wealthy
basically at 31 and um
and it was like you know zero thousand
dollars then negative thirty thousand
dollars with that first startup then i i
got a job and the job paid me a hundred
twenty thousand dollars i thought it was
great that was hundred twenty hundred
twenty hundred twenty and i went to 160
and then it like stayed there for a bit
and then i totaled it and i said
wow at age 31 i made more than the
previous 11 years before that combined
and i was like you know this is my
advice to young people always is if
you're going to take a non-traditional
path like entrepreneurship or betting on
yourself rather than a corporate career
track
corporate career track you should be
increasing you know every two years by a
certain fixed percent and you're great
that's your lifestyle if you take the
non-traditional path you go try to be a
content creator entrepreneur or
something else
it's going to be this slowly than
suddenly path and don't if you're 22
don't count your earnings at 22 or 23 or
24 you're gonna check the scoreboard at
age thirty was my my motto might be or
or regardless of 30 or not after like
eight or nine years you give it give it
a decade and you what you need to is
total it up in 10 years how did i do
versus counting every year because
you're gonna lose lose lose lose lose
win big
and uh that's off that's off to the path
so i was curious for you if you did that
is your path similar or if you charge it
out for 20s to 30s i don't know if you
want to share the exact or whatever but
yeah i can share some i mean when i sold
i had saved a
like seven figures of course that
includes my wife and i and she also uh
worked at airbnb and so airbnb went
public and she had worked there for a
long time airbnb went public in december
i sold my company in february so it was
like
uh december 1st and then like february
1st it was like those two or three
months was like massive right and so but
prior to that
take her out because we don't want to
put her business out there so let's just
talk about you um
in your early 20s what were you making
so um from age 22 to probably 26 and 27
i paid myself something like 2 grand a
month so in the brain so the first year
of business i probably paid myself 20
000 for the first year and then i paid
myself 40 000 for the next two years
and then um
70 000 and in the last year that was 24k
a year and then 40k a year and then you
said 70k roughly
you know it was like 20 40 40 70. yeah
so that's four years in and then the
year we sold i'd paid myself close to
300 thousand dollars right um and i had
a few other investments like some angel
investments and um
like some weird things that kind of paid
off but basically like for the longest
time i mean i was living i the way i
rigged it was in san francisco my rent
was only 400 because i rented out this
big place and i only had 25 grand of my
name and i spent all of it to rent out
and furnish this place and then i rented
it out to people who basically
subsidized it for me so i was living
like a poor person and um so i was able
to save a little bit of money living
like a wealthy person really you were
living in a place and it was only
costing you 400 a month which is great
example by the way because there's a lot
of people that will be like
i want to move to san francisco but i
can't afford it
all you're saying to me is
i lack creativity and resourcefulness
because what you did is available to
everybody
go find a place that's at market or
slightly below market price
and what you did i think is you cut a
deal with the landlord you were like
i'll never call you for anything yeah i
told it breaks i'll fix it you i think
you lived there for like a decade or
some [__] and you'd never like set like
seven years yeah never spoke to the
person yeah i never saw him i had i not
one said have i ever seen him if you
showed up at the house you wouldn't know
who the heck is i would not i don't even
remember what he looks like i couldn't
even tell you what he looks like i think
his name was chris and so you cut this
deal and you're like look i'm you
basically became the landlord well i
showed i showed up and i was 22 and it
was a four thousand dollar or five i
forget how much was it 4500 a month for
a four bedroom house and he goes is it
just you i go
look it's just me right now but i'm
gonna get like some friends to move in
um i'll like sign a lease a sublease
with them and i and i can have you
approve it right but basically like i'm
gonna pay you on time all the time and
my the preferred relationship you and i
have is i never see you again
and are you okay with that and he goes
yeah he goes don't don't be late and i
go okay deal and we are never late i
never one time i i i'm an idiot one time
i shot a bb gun in the toilet and it
broke the toilet and so we just went to
home depot and like bought a toilet and
just replaced it
you know what i mean so we would do
stuff like that all the time if somebody
said hey which of your friends shot a bb
gun into the toilet i feel like i'm like
oh you know sam sam's great he's a great
guy
i bought we bought like an airsoft gun
or something we're like let's see how
strong this is and we really want to
shoot it in the house because it went
through the couch
uh
anyway
anyway it yeah and so at this point yeah
so it was a slow build it took like five
six seven years but then what's crazy is
i'm 32 now i started hustling at age 20
probably 20 like making like real money
on my own like livable money and at this
point at age 32 i'll make more this year
from a couple like side investments like
a real estate deal that i did i'll make
more this year than collectively all of
my salaries combined while working at
the hustle exactly and that's that's the
exact same same case for me and i think
that's actually really common and i
think the reason i bring that up is
because
it's interesting to me b
i think that's really comforting to
people because when you're in it and
you're not making any money and it looks
like other people are all making hell of
money it feels it could feel very bad
and you can question if you're on the
right path or not and this doesn't mean
you're definitely on the right path but
it means
when this path of entrepreneurship works
that's commonly what it looks like so
don't be surprised um all right so let's
get back to you which by the way um when
i was getting going i was always so
envious
of
other people like my friends i'm like
[__] you got a job at google you make
150 grand a year and you have all these
benefits i haven't been to the doctor
forever this is awesome i'm so jealous
so you would come to you'd come to my
office and you'd be like dude this is
your office yeah yeah and then we'd be
eating something you'd be like this is
this cheese just always available whose
cheese is this
they just breathed out i felt like i
would be like you'd be like look this
cheese is from whole foods this is
expensive cheese i'm like bro
stop talking about the cheese right now
but it was like i remember you were
noticing
all those things in a funny way i was
like you guys have an espresso machine
he's got a women's bathroom what the
hell is this
machine yeah i remember i was like
freaking out that you had an expression
like espresso machine i was like what
the hell is this and i remember like i
used to take food to go
um
so anyway um yeah it accumulated quickly
and i think it for most people it's i
mean it
like i think that it's basically it's
like you're poor you're poor you're poor
and then it's like suddenly it's like oh
holy crap i'm not anymore and you know
you have that moment and there's a
subreddit called fat fire and they talk
a lot about that and there's this guy
who has a series of threads called
confessions of a hecto millionaire and
he's doing like eight parts and i linked
to it in there and five here yeah and
the mods have basically um approved it
so basically the mods have like this guy
dm'd him
dm'd his
accountants or account information or
something so they like verified that
he's uh as wealthy as he is but
basically in the beginning uh thread he
says um you know i'm
worth north of 100 million dollars i got
wealthy originally because i was an
employee at a tech company that made me
30 million dollars and that was like 15
years ago and then i invested in this
and then i did this and then i did this
and i'm going to answer a lot of the
questions that i think a lot of people
ask here and the mods have approved that
i am who i am and i'm going to tell you
all about work and purpose my time and
routine why i keep a low profile how
relationships are complicated what i
spend on a monthly basis
what my investment in portfolio
management is and it's incredibly
fascinating i love this stuff where you
get behind the scenes of people you
normally never have access to and so
it's a great series it's a great thread
uh it's awesome
awesome i love it great find um okay
let's do some more so
uh what do i want to do okay let me do
um
uh let me do it you want me to do a
quick one while you're thinking do it do
a quick one okay and i can keep right on
so you just let me know so
all right this is a little black hat
here but i'm gonna tell you so there's
this company called i think it's made by
the same company it's called web archive
it's the greatest thing ever i love web
archive and they have got this side
project called archive today so archive
dot today have you ever seen this yes i
have seen this it is awesome so if you
ever want to read so there's a bunch of
products out there on how to read
articles that are paywalled or behind
some type of like thing that you can't
see them um so there's um outline.com
which is kind of cool there's this other
one that's called um
12 foot and and yeah it's called 12-foot
ladder and so it basically says show me
attendance over the paywall yeah so
listen to the tagline show me a 10-foot
paywall i'll show you a 12-foot ladder
brilliant right genius
brilliant and it doesn't work all the
time working very well that's the
problem with 12 foot yes
yeah archive today works i've never used
it and it not work and so if you ever
want to read something and you don't
feel like paying the paper like you just
want to read like uh article and not all
like pay for it archive today is the
greatest thing i've ever seen
yeah and the internet archive is just
like a treasure right like it's a
non-profit thing it's a great way to go
look up what did the original version of
the airbnb website look like you can go
to the wayback machine which is
something they've created and you can
type in airbnb.com you can go back and
you can see oh wow it used to be called
air bed and breakfast and it was like
catered toward conferences because
that's how they initially got their
start and blah blah blah so you know the
internet archive which is the nonprofit
behind it is amazing they actually
bought our friend's company they bought
xavier's uh book company as well because
they're going to like scan all the books
and make them available for people and
things like that so they just it's it's
amazing you know they're based in inner
sunset right where my office was that's
right that's right
um okay let's do some more uh okay so
i basically made a pretty big and i
think
at the at the risk of us sounding
like
kind of like
overly obsessed with fitness which is
like ironic because at least at least
you're ripped so i think you could get
away with being obsessed with fitness
i'm not ripped yet so it's like a little
bit it's a little bit weird when i talk
too much about it but you're pretty big
investment in this because and your and
your improvement has been massive i
basically when i was how much did you
weigh when we first started filming do
you know
i have no idea but i basically gained
like 40 or 50 pounds over the course of
like my last startup
and like never lost it so you think you
weighed i used to do like 250. not 250.
i think the most everywhere was 225. and
i don't even weigh much less than that
now but it's a different weight it's
yeah it's like muscle versus fat it's
like converting right so um
so yeah i basically you know ballooned
up again you know i used to be whatever
175 or whatever and then all of a sudden
i'm 225 and felt really bad and you know
it's not healthy it doesn't look good
all this stuff i would when i would see
a photo of myself i'd think that's a bad
photo of myself and after three years
i'm like hey how come all the photos are
just bad photos of me oh wait maybe i'm
like actually just like massively out of
shape here so i invested in basically
three or four things now that have paid
off and i'll tell you one that i don't
think paid off so um
so i think fitness takes a couple things
uh at least for me and that's uh time so
i was like okay what are some things
that i if if going to the gym is taking
too much time what's a way that i can
hack that so first of all i built a home
gym so there's no going anywhere but
even me you could put a a peloton right
next to me that doesn't mean i'm gonna
ride it you can put my foot in the
straps it doesn't mean i'm gonna push
like
there was many reasons for many years
that i didn't exercise regularly and so
one was just bringing the gym home then
i got a trainer because i said well if
some dude shows up i'm not just gonna
ignore him like i'm clearly gonna like
do the workout i think that's the
biggest thing that made a difference i
like i i have a friend who is um
who who is a wealthy guy and he was like
hey can you tell me what to do and i'm
like no man get a coach for like 250
bucks a month and they'll tell you what
to do and you don't think you just do
what they say and he was like that's
really expensive i'm like dog you live
in a four million dollar house like
why do you like your your body's your
house and you're not going to spend 300
or something to fix it yeah that's wild
um
my dad does that my dad's like oh
you spend on this personal trainer five
days a week like that's crazy
uh i have this trainer i found in india
he just does it on zoom and he's only
four dollars an hour i was like four
dollars an hour he's like yeah he wanted
six but i got him down to four he was so
proud and i was like oh that's i mean
that's amazing okay is it such an indian
thing he's like yeah he's really good
he's really fit no no i was like no he's
good for you
he's like oh well i you know i don't
really do it like you know it's he's
like it's only four bucks so i don't
even mind if i skip it i was like
exactly like you literally don't do it
it's not working for you you're not
exercising regularly you're not getting
in better shape so how is it really that
good uh so anyways i invested a bunch of
stuff and i took an approach which was
like
i wanted to leave myself no outs
so i took a like burn the boat strategy
so first i talked about it publicly and
i talked about it publicly because if i
talk about it publicly i'm gonna be
humiliated if uh you know i'd feel
embarrassed if i talk about this and i
don't do it i don't back it up same
thing i did i think i vouched for that i
made it super convenient so i did home
gym and i brought i had a trainer come
to my house i paid the extra to make
sure that that happened
okay so now i'm doing the workouts okay
cool now how do i do it where i actually
enjoy it well
i invested in making the space nice so
like i went to your gym and i was like
wow this feels great i need to get a
floor like this and i bought these
rubber tiles and i did all this stuff to
make the gym feel better and i like got
like the sound system i did a bunch of
things to make the environment one where
i would not dread going there i would
enjoy i would want to go there and a
bunch of things like that so those were
all great investments i felt like great
finds for me was like these little
rubber tiles and it took time and energy
to research these and i didn't outsource
this i was like no
i need to find the best one because i
want this to feel a certain way and i i
crafted that kind of vision for myself
same thing i just got a sauna set it up
yesterday did the first sauna session in
it and i'm like this is amazing um it's
sick right already already this is one
of my great purchases of the year and i
just have had it for one day
i got this clear light sauna infrared
sauna
and i know that some people are like
don't do infrared and some people are
like buy this other brand instead
whatever no clear light's good clear
that's a great brand uh
you know but some people are like you
should do the dry sauna not the infrared
from what i could tell um it's totally
fine and it's uh importantly it fit into
my life whereas the other one would have
required like
a whole bunch of like waiting
for like a bigger space and electrical
and all this changes to be made in order
to work as long as it can get hot enough
it's good yeah exactly so those have
been for me the best one now here's the
worst the worst buys the worst things i
did
i anything that i attached to my wrist
has just failed so
um
i bought an apple watch
um lost it
got stolen slash watched i don't know
what happened it was at the office and
it was gone um
second one uh bought a fitbit lost it
whoop band have it battery's dead don't
charge it regularly enough for it to be
useful
um so everything i've tried that's like
a fitness tracker that is like a
wearable device
it doesn't work for me because i'm too
disorganized and lose [__] and don't
keep things charged and ready for the
morning and then charge it for sleep i
had an ura ring i lost that too uh i
have i have failed on like five
wearables this year so i got same count
myself out on that do you wear a wedding
ring i lost my wedding ring as well so
that's the same you know for bonus
points dude that's why i wear these like
uh 20 rubber ones yeah mine was only a
60 wedding ring anyways so i didn't feel
i mean the sentimental loss yeah but uh
you know i kind of knew that hey i don't
know if i'm a ring guy i never ring in
my life yeah and sure enough just taking
it on and off ended up i lost mine the
first week so yeah i lost mine on my
honeymoon
the world's best husband all right
okay let me give you a different one
have here we go let's shift to media
uh great podcasts articles youtube
channels whatever that we really like
i have a whole category called canceled
comedians
which is
like there's a whole bunch of people
that i love their content
they're cancelled by you know society
but i love they're still they're just as
funny as they were before everybody
found out that they like you know like
to have sex with 18 year old girls or
whatever like um so there's this guy
crystalia who got canceled i don't know
a year ago
i found him really funny before i find
him really funny now and he also has
these little like almost like
inspirational moments in between the
comedy
that i love there's this video he has
called life rips have you heard this
video
no but i love him all he's saying is
like
uh you know this [__] was happening in
my day or whatever and he's like he has
this phrase life rips which is like he's
saying like life is awesome and he's
like just remember he's like
life rips and then he he he tells the
story it's just he's a great storyteller
amazing storyteller
he tells a story about life rips
it's a feel-good moment it's a reminder
that actually yeah you're right instead
of focusing on my problems all day let
me just focus on the fact that life
actually really freaking rips and um and
then he brings that in he brings that as
a call back into a bunch of other
podcasts that he does where he'll tell a
little story he's like you know this is
a life rips moment
and just that philosophy has like made
me really happy he does this thing also
where
some he'll be recording the episode and
you'll relate to this
he's he's kind of like um
i think a lot of great entrepreneurs and
artists are this way where they're like
sort of like perfectionists in a way
like they want things to go well they
want well well-made stuff
and so let's say there's a technical
problem where he's like um he's like
let's pull up that clip and then like
the computer crashes or like somebody
walks by and unplugs his microphone like
midway through or whatever like kicks
out the power cord to the lamp
and instead of in that moment getting
mad he just has he just replaced it with
this thing where he just goes
yes the cord ripped out of the wall
he'll just like he'll be like
yes we can't find the file or he'll be
like
yes dude yes we absolutely can't show
the thing i'm talking about yes nobody
has any idea what i'm trying to say and
he just like instead of being like oh no
this sucks which is like such a pattern
that we can fall into
he just does this little yes thing
and i kind of stole it in my daily life
my wife hates it she thinks it's like
very annoying that i do this like she
doesn't understand what i'm doing she
doesn't know the reference not she will
but it really she doesn't list the
podcast either so she still probably
won't but
it's such a hack dude it's such a hack
to just
instead of just letting this little
inconvenience this little thing that
went wrong
f up your mood
just like
rewire the response to something that's
almost iron it's like sarcastic but it
actually becomes real by the time you do
it jocko who's this guy who goes on joe
rogan he does the same thing he's just
like it's crazy i don't know maybe
sealed type dude super hardcore and his
whole thing is around like you know pain
is good and so like he'll be like um
you know oh you got shin splints good
like just running i love that it gets me
fired up
he'll be like you know oh you know your
uber ride didn't show up good time to
have a hike it's like you know he
replaces of uh that sucks yeah good
time to time to get tough or good
good gotta go earn more money lost all
mine like you know whatever it's like
almost comedic how like how extreme he
is with it
but not gonna lie this [__] actually
works and so that's my that's my content
recommendation do you have um i've got a
all right i've got a bunch but do you
have a car any type of cardio machine at
your house a treadmill yeah
um and a rubber all right yeah you do
have a rower i have like a light you
have like a rower that makes you feel
like you're on the swiss canal or
whatever i have like a rinky dink you
know 120 costco rover all right i don't
think you're going to want to do this
then but i was going to say tomorrow so
i've been doing i'll do it on my
shipping i've been doing these things
where like i'm like all right everyone
this sunday 60 minute row poster results
such a impressive fitness influencer
move motivating
do you have a but you don't have a bike
do you have a bike
i have a bicycle not like a not a spin
bike i have a cab it might be easier if
you do in the back so i'm gonna get up
early tomorrow like 7 30 or maybe seven
and i'll get this thing done
and you just post your results and be
like i just and so i tweeted out i go
tomorrow it's a 90 minute day we gotta
because and people are like isn't that
boring and i'm like yes
that is the point we should go through
pain tomorrow before we get thankful
right so if you want to do it with me uh
do a 90 minute any type of 90 minute
steady cardio
um
good i don't think you know when i watch
my kids
well
well that's why you gotta get up really
early to do it you gotta like go through
hard uh some hardships i don't think
you're gonna be able to run for 90
minutes but even like a brisk walk
honestly for 90 could work but just like
as long as your heart rate's like 140
140-ish um
all right let me let me let me let me
tell you uh five or four i'm going to go
fast on some bits of media the first
this happened earlier this year there's
this amazing video of rose nambiunis
this
awesome ufc fighter but the reason she's
interesting is she's like really quiet
and introspective and seems like a
sweetheart not like a fighter and
there's this amazing video of her about
to fight this badass woman from china
who just looks like the terminator and
she's repeating to herself i'm the best
i'm the best i'm the best and when i
first saw that i teared up it's the
greatest
it pumps me up it's amazing the second
thing primitive technology by the way
can i just give a recommendation there
for people who don't follow the ufc
they're going to watch this thing back
whatever uh you know if even if they
went and watched it it wouldn't have the
same emotional resonance it resonated
for you because you know how much of a
terminator that other girl is you know
rose's backstory and she struggles with
anxiety she's not a bravado type of
person so for her to say i'm the best
it's not
bravado and trash talk it's literally
self-talk so she you know can perform
her best and not let anxiety get the
best of her so you know the backstory
but i think everybody should have these
go-to's these this stash of like
inspiring moments that you were there
for that you know the context you know
the backstory and then you could just
put them it's like that flooding thing i
was talking about earlier you can just
go back to it and you can instantly get
that feeling um and you should just have
a well of these which i like i i think
that people should know that i mean like
successful people i don't know if people
consider me successful or not but i know
that like way more successful people
than i
do this but i rely on like like i'll
like read a book about someone who i
admire and i'm like how would this
person react to this situation totally
like i i do that all the time or i'm
like sometimes i'll even do it with like
ufc fighters i'm like this guy just got
punched in the face and he got up like i
can do it
um so i like that rose number units
thing the second thing is primitive
technology have you heard of primitive
technology no what's that
click the link it's in there so
this guy
has 10 million subscribers on youtube
in his videos of which there are
how many are there maybe
we've talked about this guy he's like
caveman
yeah
there's maybe only 20 videos and his
very first video has 31 million views it
was six years ago and it's him not
talking not saying a word he's in the
woods and he's building a hut and
eventually it works out to build like a
proper house and he does it without
saying a word and he does it with only
using things that he finds in the woods
no power tools no nothing he builds a
kiln he builds a tiled roof
i'm on that video it starts and she's
just pan the camera is just planning at
this just this spot on the ground in the
middle of the forest
it's clear like there's nothing here i'm
going to build a little hut here
click to the end
he's doing that like a clay hut
with a fireplace in there with a
fireplace and a chimney
yes
and the whole video he doesn't say a
single word all you do is he's literally
his bare hands
yes just building it and then he'll like
make like a hammer out of like uh some
he'll make rope and then he'll make a
hammer out a rope and a stick or a a
rock and a stick
do you know this guy's backstory like
this guy looks just like everybody i
went to duke with like who is this guy
and why does he tell us it's in
australia i believe and he owns this
land and so if you go to his about page
he just it just says where is this and
he goes queensland australia do you live
in that wild i don't live in the wild
but i love going out into the land i do
these projects yeah
and so
he doesn't talk much he doesn't do
anything his channel has gotten one
billion views and all he's doing is
building like dude there's another one
i'm watching him
make fire just with he's just rubbing
his hands together like this
with a stick in between
he just made a fire while you were
talking it's so relaxing it's so awesome
i love it so do you i love to be honest
do you actually want because i see this
i'm like this is so cool
and i like click through one and then
i'll be like oh this is just something
i'm gonna go tell other people about i
don't i wouldn't never actually sit here
and watch this for 30 minutes i've
watched all of them
do you have apple do you have apple tv
uh no i don't but i have apple tv so
my version of tv is youtube so first
thing when i sit down the couch i go
straight to youtube and i'll just watch
like a 30 this 30 it's like this is like
that tv show how stuff's built do you
remember that yeah but you do it in the
background or you actually just watch
pay attention to him
yeah maybe i'll like be talking to sarah
or cooking
yeah i'm like oh my god wait watch this
look what he's doing yeah maybe it's in
the background i mean do you i don't
actually sit down and really watch tv
unless it's a movie um or the challenge
or the challenge okay so this is amazing
okay primitive technology all right let
me keep going let me keep going um i'm
gonna roll okay the the third one how to
be great just be good repeatedly this is
an article by steph smith who works for
me there's two reasons why i love this
article the first that is one of the
best headlines i've ever read yes it is
a wonderful headline and she writes this
article about
how
great things rarely uh are you like
trying to be great it's more so just
like being kind of good but doing it
consistently and in my life i have found
that with this podcast with a bunch of
other stuff
like i'm like
i don't want to do this today it's like
all right fine i'm going to do it anyway
even though i know today i'm not going
to do a good job of it i'm just going to
get it done and she does a really good
job of articulating why that works so i
love that article
um all right i'm gonna keep going um
the the next one there's this guy who's
got a youtube channel called more plates
more dates yeah i watch this guy
he is amazing he looks at pro athletes
and actors and he and he's a i guess
he's a i think he's a doctor i don't
know what his background is he sounds
like he knows what he's talking about
and he tells you what steroids he thinks
different people are on
i watch season every time i do i regret
so much i'm like what a waste of my life
i just did um
but i he comes up in my feed and i'm
like oh i know that person yeah are they
on steroids and then like
30 minutes later i'm like i cannot
believe i've let this be in my brain for
the last 30 minutes what a waste of my
brain
it's interesting though because they'll
explain like the science behind it he's
like you he's like a lot of people think
that this athlete is doing epo you
wouldn't do epo because the way that
your body works is this this this and
this and he like it so it's kind of
interesting he goes but you would do hgh
because the way hgh works is it's proven
to do so it's like a science it's
interesting all right and then
but yeah there's a little bit of science
it's gossip from a person who i believe
is reputable uh not in having firsthand
knowledge of the people but firsthand
knowledge and doping and the final thing
i found this book it has two reviews on
amazon
um
only two reviews on amazon it's amazing
and so apparently the in the for or in
the forward they say that's one of the
most popular books in russia but i i
didn't know that and they translated it
into english so these two journalists
from the ussr in 1933
made a deal with the us government that
they would let them come in and spend
three months doing a road trip and so
they saved up a little bit of money they
came here and they bought a camper van
and they spent three months traveling
america talking to people with nothing
to do really just all they just wanted
to learn about of america and from an
outside perspective they show what makes
america special and it's incredibly
fascinating because we take a lot of
things for granted and they criticize
america and this is in the 1930s so this
is this point is particularly
particularly true they criticize like
our race relations and things like that
this is like this is crazy how people
treat each other but
there is a lot of good including they
say there's something about americans
that i've never seen ever before which
is they always think that they are going
to overcome any adversity and they
always are optimistic about like some
situation and also
oddly they're friends with their bosses
so like they work together to achieve
things and they don't like like their
friend like you could be friends with
your boss and you cannot hate them or
want to rob from them right and people
are and and it's a wonderful book it's
written in the 30s it's awesome so
that's my book oh it's called uh little
golden america nice
uh that's great you've read you had the
whole thing
i've yeah i'm finishing it up now and i
actually posted a link on my twitter
where it's free like a pdf
uh okay cool i like that um okay i have
a couple quick ones so
a chrome extension that i'm liking a lot
it's called everyday
and it's basically a habit tracker so um
so if you go to the website i think it's
called everyday
let me just find the everyday.app i
think is the thing
um
and basically you just say what you want
to do so you're like i wanna like for me
for example i have morning routine i
have clean lunch clean dinner
um i have workout i have my uh
gratitude thing and then
that's it and so and then basically what
it does is it just lets you create a
streak so you just say yes i did it this
day i uh i intentionally skipped it i'm
allowed to skip it or i missed and it
just keeps track of your streaks and it
creates this awesome green grid of like
as you do your habits you get this
really satisfying completion of like
your grid being green it just shows i'm
doing the things i said i wanted to do
which for me is and most people is all
of the challenges all of the challenges
not oh i just don't know what to do it's
i'm not doing the [__] i know i should
do
and um so this is just you know a great
tool and i think it's great because it's
chrome extension so it's in your face
you don't have to remember to check it
it's every time you open a new tab in
your browser it's going to remind you oh
yeah
i could i knock that out right now you
know yeah i could actually just do that
right now and i can get it done um so
it's a i actually have my own chrome
extension and i've replaced it with this
one that's how good it is so um you know
this is one of my one of my favorites
downloading it now
okay let me give you a couple other
things that i think are really cool you
showed me this camo
it's an app for your iphone now we spent
a lot of money and time
you may not be able to tell right now
because we're both not in our main
studio or i'm not in my main studio
you're you're in a different spot i look
good i don't know i don't know
no i'm not traveling
you've been traveling so yeah you know
on different videos we have different
level of quality or whatever
but we did
we both tried on our own and then we
hired people to like hey uh how do
people get that fancy ass blur and like
super hd video it's so hard and they're
like oh you got to buy this uh canon uh
which one 50d 40d 60 70 which which d do
i buy okay i'll get this one oh then i
need like some kind of um
cord or like a capture card or how am i
gonna do that it's so much tripod
paint a butt batteries oh but the
battery's gonna die during the episode
so you have to actually get a double
battery or a dummy battery pain in the
ass
so and it's thousands of dollars for the
camera itself was like 1500 or something
like that so it's really expensive
and you were like oh dude i'm just using
this iphone app called camo that just
you just download the app and then uh
it just uses the native iphone like
portrait mode to make your camera look
good
and you're like look i'm just using my
phone i look just as good as you i was
like yeah i'm using the 2000 thing and
it's really hard to set up
dude it's sick it's only 30 bucks and
look i'm traveling and i just bring this
with me because it's my phone i was like
oh my god it's i think it's 40 or 50
bucks i don't know if this is it 30
maybe it's i don't remember i actually
think in the new ios it's just this is
just baked in actually i think they i
don't think you even need this anymore
um
but for now and if i don't if i'm wrong
about that ios you mean it's coming out
soon like in the new ios there's gonna
be part of the native camera so you
don't need an app to do this i think
but one coming out soon or one out now i
don't know it's now soon something um
something like that so but in the
meantime this app camo is kind of
amazing uh great business by whoever's
doing this and amazing timing because
the whole world went remote and
everybody wants to look good so uh
that's definitely one of the best
products the analogy we made or someone
made is having camo it's like
in the 70s and 80s and 90s when it
mattered that you wore a suit having a
camo is like showing up in a meeting in
a nice suit
exactly exactly
um
so so i think that's a great uh product
okay i'm gonna give you a youtube
channel so you did more plates more
dates um the binge i've been on is
is like kind of embarrassing almost it's
these old-school direct sales
seminars
so i'm like okay how do i um
i don't know why i like this i'm not
even doing anything that has direct
sales like there's not a product i sell
that's direct sales i'm not a salesman
i've never been one
uh but i'm just like fascinated with the
art of persuasion and say which ones and
so um so there's a couple that are
really good last night like for example
i fell asleep last night while listening
to it if you just search tony robbins
sales rare and it's like uh there's two
there's one where he explains how he
sold how he got his career started he
doesn't talk about this much he got his
career started selling audio cassettes
like music music tapes to people um
you know to to people and he'd do these
like
you know he'd go and he's like yeah like
the way we would do it is a woman would
reach out to the potential customer and
they would say we'd love to have uh we'd
love to give you a free gift
and um we'd love to tell you a little
bit about our company and it'd be a free
gift he said yeah it's a free gift it's
usually worth 100
um and we'd love to give it to you and
you know feel if you'd meet with our
person and then tony was that person and
he would be like he would walk through
the step-by-step thing and he'd be like
i would say this and why am i saying
that i'm saying that because
blah blah blah here's the thing about
how people buy he's like and he's got
his whole philosophy and he even says in
this thing he's like you know
would i do this now no because i feel
like it's a little too pushy and but i'm
always the type where i wanna know
what's the real potent [__] that works i
wanna know the borderline illegal
version of sailing and persuasion and
then it's up to me to decide
am i going to keep the knob on level 12
or do i want to turn it down to nine but
i don't want to look at this i don't
want to be at level six because i was
too afraid to ever find out what is what
does maximum persuasion look like you
know what is what's the channel called
uh i don't i just look at the individual
videos there's not any channels so like
gary halpert rare or gary halpert 1980s
or gary halpert original seminar tony
robbins young tony robbins rare tony
robbins original seminar tony robbins
direct sales tony robbins infomercial
and i'll go either i'll just find their
material and i'll deconstruct it myself
like what's working like we had craig
clemons on and craig clemens comes on
the podcast and he's a friend of ours
and he's uh doesn't he he's a great
person on the pod but he doesn't go
first he doesn't talk a lot about his
company so he's got gold and hippo
they've sold like over you know i think
he sold over a billion billion dollars
worth of product in his lifetime uh and
gold and hipaa will do you know over a
hundred million dollars in sales but
it's like hey what golden hippo is a
holding company what are the companies
underneath and he doesn't really like go
list out the 13 companies or whatever
however many there are underneath it
um nobody really pushes him for that and
he's kind of like at the made it stage
now but his he got his start early on
doing sales for a guy who's like a
dating coach and it was like i bought
that dude you're dating and like how to
how to
basically it's all different titles that
all mean how to get laid and if it was a
wife i was like how do you get the man
of your dreams how to get a husband how
to whatever and he taught and so i find
these old interviews or old seminars he
did with that guy eben pagan and i'll go
watch those and i'll see oh interesting
he's talking about this headline he
wrote and why this headline is amazing
why he thinks it worked and this other
one and why it totally didn't work and
what he learned from that and i just
find these to be like it's like puppy
chow to me it's just i i can't stop
consuming it even though i really have
no direct use for it uh i just love it
so i'll tell you guys listening um gary
halbert so gary halbert's this guy he
died somewhat recently from just like a
heart attack or something and he was an
amazing copywriter and he might have
died in prison or
soon after he was in prison for a
handful of years because he sold
something ironically that's the guy i
want to learn from
yes and the world famous that's why you
took it too far
like wall street i'm gonna learn from
him i'm not gonna take it as far but i
wanna learn from that person i think he
went to prison for mail fraud or
something like that so basically people
bought stuff and he just didn't fulfill
it and so he was just like i sold it and
i just lied and
that's obviously wrong but you can learn
a lot from him and he's got these
amazing things called um
the letters from boron
they're boron letters sorry and they're
all free so if you google gary halbert
boron letters you can find them for free
it's a series of letters that he wrote
his son bond from prison and he teaches
him everything he knows about life and
selling yes and so like you can go and
read it he wrote them all by hand
because i was just so and you're going
to read it you're like why would you why
is this so good
it's so good if you know why it's so
good it's almost like that it's like
it's no it's clearly good like you start
you fall down like his slippery slope
you're like why is this so interesting
why do i want to keep reading this
exactly you don't know it's not like
like it's not a um
it's what i'll call a door not a window
so
a window opportunity is one where you
look right in and you could see what's
in it for you and you're like oh okay
like for example let's say you wanted to
get better at copywriting the thing is
not called how to get better at
copywriting and he doesn't say here's
five copywriting techniques no he
actually
writes these as letters to his son and
then he just shows you great copywriting
and then he sprinkles in lessons as he
goes but it doesn't come to like letter
five or whatever there's like it takes
you you're just interested you're hooked
and you don't know why and that's the
technique and then you gotta like figure
out why is this so damn good what is it
about this writing style that's so
slippery that i just can't get it's like
a tick-tock feed i can't get out of it
you know and so
i would say it's like more like a door
where you kind of got to go knock and
take a leap of faith that there is
something on the other side of this you
can't see exactly what you're going to
get until the door opens
yeah this is a winner um
all right well i think
i think we just like laid out a ton of
interesting stuff uh ben are you there
and by the way we should put uh links to
as much of these as we can in the show
notes i'm also gonna send out a
newsletter of just like summarizing
these
um just on like whatever my own like my
weekly newsletter whatever seanprey.com
and because i think these are actually
really good but most people listening to
this it's probably really [__] hard
to be like what am i supposed to write
these down and go google all these
different things these guys are talking
about yeah you need the links
what do you think ben yeah it's gonna be
great at the bottom of the show notes
we'll just put a long list of all the
links so people can find everything but
this is awesome
we'll just spew in cool products that we
consume by the way i there's i i have
half of you told me about this two
minutes or you told me before but i was
busy i learned about this premise two
minutes before the show and i actually
still have like five things that i we
didn't even get to and i know you have
like 10 things we didn't even get to so
we may want to if people like this we
may want to do one more of these i like
it and the point of this is it's
supposed to be thanksgiving special
right so you guys are just if you're fat
with turkey you're sitting on your couch
you've got some time on your hands you
can just start clicking through all
these links check out all this stuff buy
some stuff
watch some things have a good time i
think it's mostly free stuff by the way
that we mentioned
yeah a lot of it is free or very cheap
um
ben i love that uh that sales pitch
right there that was great who
have you been watching these videos too
are we are we sharing youtube accounts
what's going on
yeah i just had to step up my game after
you're talking about all this uh
copywriting and sales stuff
that's the mormon in you you guys are
natural sales people you guys are the
world's greatest sales people
will mormon jokes never get old
no probably not
some stereotypes we have so few
stereotypes we're allowed to access
these days that when there is one that
feels like it's okay you just gotta hit
it over and over again
good i'm down well thank you all right
i'm out i gotta go be with my family see
ya happy thanksgiving
[Music]
you